I live in rooms just waiting to be
turned to a labyrinth love
we could order pizza tell those stories
party in my labyrinth her love it will
be sweet come down let us prolly if I
totally don't blanket fort yes I know
what you're saying do that before sucks
that will be the first time I've heard
such criticism its structural integrity
is dubious at best but come on it's not
like I'm a freaking architect or
anything
I live in rooms just waiting to be
turned into a labyrinth full of I have
vast resources of cushions like a Taj
Mahal this beauty is inspired by a
special ages is erected in respect to
the construction and open to suggestion
so this book is a shared vision as our
shelter is erected in respecting the
construction and open to suggestions so
this far as a chef it's just waiting to
be turned into a labyrinth
this baby's just a prototype let's
frolic in my labyrinth
totally don't blanket for PS I'm allowed
to have sleepovers
humpin it yeah what he's very offended
he's hiding behind his hat